[Música]
comenzamos reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros en
septiembre de 2020 estalló una disputa
entre armenia y azerbaiyán en el sur del
cáucaso los dos países luego de 30 años
de calma empezaron a combatir de nuevo
en nagorno karabaj a una disputada
región por la que ambos pelean se
esperaba que las tensiones terminarán
rápidamente como ya había ocurrido en
otras ocasiones pero no fue así en pocos
días la batalla se convirtió en guerra
duró seis semanas y dejó cerca de seis
mil muertos
azerbayán derrotó a armenia y el
ejército hacer y conquistó varios
territorios que antes estaban
controlados por las fuerzas armadas nos
acompaña a de a rocha nuestro
corresponsal en turquía y enviado
especial la cara bajo una zona donde
conviven codo a codo la euforia de la
victoria militar y la miseria que ha
dejado la guerra
adrià bienvenido a reporteros y empiezo
por preguntarle sobre las dificultades
que tuvo durante la realización de este
reportaje
fue complicado sobre todo porque las
regiones que tengo quizás por hacer
vayan estas regiones siguen en el
mercado no se nos permitió en ningún
momento hacer solos y siempre tuvimos
que estar bajo el control estricto de la
policía de azerbaiyán ellos anuncian era
por la presencia de minas en la región
han sido largas y dominada ahora mismo
durante esta guerra tanto también como
lo fue en la década de los 90 con la
primera guerra del karabaj y además la
policía tampoco nos permitió hablar con
quisieran conseguirían en todo momento y
que les informaremos que estaba en
contacto directo con nuestro traductor
para exponer saber en todo momento con
quién hablamos para intentar esquivar un
poco esa censura al abandonar a
azerbayán en estambul entrevistamos
algunos azerbayanos que no viven en su
país ellos a diferencia de los que se
quedaron
[Música]
de lo que ha ocurrido en nuestras
últimas semanas
adrià pues muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros regresamos con usted en
minutos antes vamos a ver el reportaje
que usted le hizo
[Música]
hace casi 30 años la última vez que
estuvo aquí y mala had cool y eba aún no
puede creérselo aquí
esta mujer pasó media vida aquí jugaba
cuando era pequeña aquí pensaba que
nunca más volvería pero lo ha conseguido
ahora dicen andar aquí estaba la
mezquita veníamos mucho cuando vivíamos
aquí al lado había un centro comercial
de tres plantas donde comprábamos la
ropa
delante estaba el parque de lenin y
vamos mucho
que decir era una vida de pueblo
málaga ha vuelto a una ciudad que
durante la unión soviética era un centro
de comercio y tenía varias decenas de
miles de habitantes
pero los años 90 la primera guerra del
karabaj los armenios la conquistaron
expulsaron a todos sus habitantes y la
convirtieron en lo que es ahora una
ciudad fantasma
pues acería estos únicos que la poblaban
antes de esa guerra la conocen como la
giro sima del cáucaso
es fácil de entender porque
en otoño de 2020 la guerra volvió a
estas tierras azerbayán reconquistó
acdam y ahora al fin tras media vida
esperando mala hat no cree en lo que
está viendo desde la ocupación esta es
la primera vez que vuelvo es peor mucho
peor de lo que me imaginaba teníamos una
ciudad preciosa
cómo se sentirían ustedes si volviesen a
su ciudad después de 30 años y la viesen
así pues yo me siento así de mal si mala
hut que en la primera guerra del karabaj
perdió a su hermano su marido y su
ciudad ha podido regresar es gracias a
miles de combatientes como polat ese
soldado de las fuerzas especiales perdió
ambos pies en octubre del año pasado
estaba pasando por unas montañas y al
llegar a la cima pisé una mina explotó y
me lanzo contra otra mina
con la primera perdía un pie y la
segunda me hizo perder el otro todo sólo
hago con pasión han tomado son solo
ocurrió no muy lejos de estas tierras
repletas de trincheras y destrucción en
la región de friuli aquí no hace tanto
armenios y acérquese bombardeaban
disparaban y mataban por amor a su
patria y odio a la del enemigo
ahora a la espera de que le operen y le
pongan dos prótesis pola está guarda en
su casa en un barrio muy humilde a las
afueras de la capital de azerbaiyán baku
sobre su sacrificio dice no arrepentirse
absolutamente de nada
porque me tendría que arrepentir
no es un problema
he sido herido por la patria que viva la
patria estaba preparado para hacer este
camino para sacrificar me en el para
azerbaiyán
nada de esto es sobre nuestros mártires
sobre nuestros heridos
y esto va a recuperar nuestras tierras
de las manos de nuestros enemigos
pero porque pola decidió jugarse la vida
por una bandera que lleva a un joven
hacer y a morir y matar por su país en
las montañas del karabaj de dónde sale
el odio que armenio se hace día se
procesa la respuesta está en la
importancia que para estas dos pequeñas
naciones tiene el nagorno karabaj
[Música]
divinity durante la unión soviética se
disputa por poseer esta región quedó
congelada bajo el mando de moscú y el
ejército rojo pero con la perestroika de
mijail gorbachov la tensión entre los
dos pueblos se multiplicó
tras algunos episodios de violencia fue
en 1991 con la unión soviética y ya
agonizando cuando armenia y azerbaiyán
se declararon la guerra
[Música]
el conflicto duró hasta 1994 y murieron
en tres años cerca de 30.000 personas
esa guerra la primera de alcalá baja la
ganó armenia y estableció la nueva
república armenia de nagorno karabaj o
un nuevo país dentro de territorio
internacionalmente reconocido de
azerbayán
pero las fuerzas armenias fueron más
allá con el fervor de la victoria a los
armenios conquistaron por la fuerza a
las siete regiones a celis que rodeaban
las montañas de alcalá baja en ellas
actam era la mayor ciudad nunca habían
vivido armenios medio millón de
azerbaiyanos fueron expulsados o huyeron
escapando de los fusiles empujados por
armenios y así durante 26 años las armas
callaron
hasta el 27 de septiembre de 2020
ese día azerbayán declaró una ofensiva
en el karabaj llevando a una guerra que
en seis semanas ha causado la muerte de
cerca de 6000 personas mayormente de
jóvenes de entre 18 y 20 años
la guerra terminó el 10 de noviembre
2020 con la firma del armisticio entre
los líderes ruso armenio y 'hacer y
armenia que aún controla parte del
karabaj fue severamente derrotada en el
campo de batalla de efecto entregar las
siete provincias azerís conquistadas en
la primera guerra
[Música]
para los armenios el acuerdo del 10 de
noviembre fue una rendición humillante
carlos hacer es una victoria casi total
germán están gordos del ejército de
armenia ya no existe ya no está no hemos
destruido y si intentan despertar a su
fascismo armenio de nuevo nuestro puño
de hierro lo destruirá
billy wright pero no todos en azerbayán
celebran la victoria en el país
caucásico cualquiera que haya estado en
contra de la guerra ha sido perseguido y
silenciado arruga y bu la prevista
opositora vive en estambul desde hace
años y no pisa su país natal desde 2014
ese año se le informó de que si volvía a
su país sería arrestada y me hiciera
algo más cada año pienso que puede ser
que esta vez sí que pueda volver pero
nunca lo consigo
pero ahora ya no sé si nunca más volveré
la verdad no sé si quiero volver
porque ha sido tan difícil ver todo lo
que está pasando
y no sé creo que necesito tiempo para
recuperarme y decidir si quiero volver o
no
y lo que le ha pasado a esta periodista
han sido amenazas de muerte y de
violación constantes contra ella tanto
por redes sociales como por medios
afines al gobierno hacer y le han
llamado traidora espía y prostituta el
único motivo estar en contra de la
guerra
verbal hasta que manden quise
documentarlo todo y cuanto más leía peor
me sentía fue muy agotador
emocionalmente y muy difícil de entender
de dónde viene esta rabia
porque esa gente puede estar tan llena
de odio
[Música]
gates
con el mismo rechazo hacia la guerra
hamid aquí has baile llegó a turquía
hace unas semanas esta activista para la
paz abandonó a azerbayán en octubre por
la presión que le causaba el conflicto
tras media vida luchando para la paz
entre los pueblos del cáucaso jamila no
pudo soportar ver a su país dentro de
una espiral de muerte que en ese momento
parecía infinita
era algo muy difícil de procesar para mí
y entiendo por mi trabajo y durante años
de dónde viene este odio pero era
demasiado para mí no esperaba que
hubiese tanto odio y creo que buena
parte de él proviene de la propaganda
gubernamental y como han
instrumentalizado los traumas de la
gente
esta activista exiliada después de pasar
unos días en estambul se mudara a
georgia de donde espera poder volver en
poco tiempo a su azerbayán natal de lo
que no tiene tantas esperanzas sin
embargo es de que la paz entre armenios
y hacer
llegué pronto
hay muchas cosas que pasaron en el
pasado que aún evocan muchas emociones
y este trabajo no se ha realizado
hay mucho trabajo que hacer para
preparar a la gente para la paz
y eso no se consigue sólo con acuerdos
gubernamentales
y mientras tanto el fervor de la
victoria continúa los azerbayanos
disfrutan de haber derrotado a sus
enemigos y de que como les pasó a ellos
hace 30 años sean ahora los armenios los
que tienen que huir el pueblo demanda
guix fue renombrado a su colusión
después de que azerbaiyán la conquista
se durante la batalla las familias
armenios que aquí vivían escapar
y la escuela donde sus hijos antes
estudiaban se ha convertido en un lugar
desértico
ahora los azerbayanos esperan repoblar
el lugar jalic que fue expulsado de
magda x hace 30 años recordaba cómo era
su pueblo a través de videos que
encontraba en internet hoy viéndolo con
sus propios ojos es la persona más feliz
del mundo
durante estos últimos 30 años nuestros
niños nos preguntaban por qué nos
expulsaron de nuestras tierras que
hicieron ustedes no podíamos responder
era difícil responder pero nuestro
presidente y nuestro ejército han
respondido gracias a dios estamos de
vuelta somos felices
al final una cosa está clara solo cuando
la felicidad de unos no se imponga la de
los otros podrá haber paz en alcalá baja
hasta que ese momento llegue la historia
de guerras exilio muerte y destrucción
está condenada a repetirse en las
montañas del cáucaso
regresamos con adriana rocha él es
nuestro corresponsal en turquía y
enviado especial a karabaj a adrià una
vez terminado el conflicto y la batalla
se espera que los dos gobiernos puedan
retomar negociaciones para solucionar de
una vez por todas el conflicto
se espera pero se crean varias paradojas
en este caso azerbayán que es quien ganó
esta guerra hace unas semanas asegura
ahora mismo que ellos están dispuestos a
enterrar las hachas a vivir ya volver
otra vez en paz a abrir las fronteras
que llevan décadas cerradas con armenia
ya intentar retomar las relaciones entre
otros gobiernos de problemas que desde
la perspectiva azerbayana también se
llama a los armenios enemigos y al
presidente de azerbaiyán ilham alíev ha
llamado en varios discursos a los
armenios perros además de enemigos por
lo tanto no se espera que en los
próximos meses aunque sea incluso años
que pueda llegar a una perspectiva de
paz tampoco desde armenia se espera
porque al ser derrotada armenia viven
muchísimos traumas ahora mismo y el
gobierno de armenia está siendo muy
discutidos al punto de que el primer
ministro armenio estuvo a punto de ser
asesinado después de la firma del
armisticio del acuerdo de paz ahora
mismo se espera que su gobierno ni
cualquiera que pueda venirle después
pueda permitirse políticamente intentará
un reproche y un relacionamiento con
azerbayán
a esto se suma a adrià la aparición de
diferentes vídeos en internet que están
mostrando la violación a los derechos
humanos de ambos bandos qué pasará con
estas pruebas
[Música]
pues ahora mismo la gran duda de lo que
queda para resolver este conflicto hay
algunos soldados aún prisioneros
armenios presionados en azerbayán y
estos vídeos han estado apareciendo
durante las últimas semanas y meses que
están creando aún muchísimo más trauma
en ambas poblaciones pero sobre todo en
la armenia porque armenia es quien ha
perdido a esta guerra y la mayoría de
vídeos que se han visto en internet son
de soldados azerbaiyanos o fusilando o
dando palizas a los soldados
venidos a detenidos de este tema
hablamos con un asesor del gobierno de
azerbayán el gobierno cerrarán y ya ha
detenido cuatro desosado sin embargo
sólo han detenido a cuatro durante todos
estos últimos meses aunque existen
muchísimas pruebas de que hayan
muchísimos más casos que los aseguró que
estos casos serán estudiados y definidos
sus autores
a cualquiera que haya cometido alguna
acción que viole la ley humanitaria
internacional que está incorporada en la
ley de azerbaiyán verá cómo le ocurren
acciones legales en su contra de propia
ley del actions against dispersas a esta
es determinación total del gobierno de
azerbaiyán wood y la subversión acabó
mal adrià ahora turquía quiere
proponerse como mediadora entre armenia
y azerbayán y pedirle a rusia también su
mediación la presencia de estos dos
países en el conflicto serviría para
llegar a una hipotética paz
en un principio podría ser porque
azerbayán es la aliada número uno de
turquía y rusia es la aliada número uno
de armenia mientras los gobiernos los
rusos el truco hay muy buena relación
sin embargo existen muchas dudas de que
estos dos gobiernos puedan llegarse a un
acuerdo para la paz
por ejemplo porque tu día fue uno de los
grandes inspiradores
aquí en septiembre del año pasado una
guerra empezase con sus clones y los
ataques que han realizado
de hecho se especula de que turquía
probablemente él fue quien encomendó el
ejército de azerbayán en la guerra
además rusia también estuvo
relativamente interesadas en el
conflicto durante lo más posible porque
el gobierno de rusia y el gobierno de
armenia en el argumento actual no tienen
muy buenas relaciones el gobierno actual
de armenia salió de una revolución una
revuelta popular anti cosa
anticorrupción y eso dificulta muchísimo
que putin y el presidente y el primer
ministro actual de armenia nico parcial
puedan entenderse por lo tanto estas dos
naciones además pugnan entre ellas en
distintos sitios tanto en alcaraz como
hemos visto hace pocos medios como
también en siria y en libia por lo tanto
la involucración tan alta que estamos
viendo ahora mismo de rusia y turquía en
este conflicto puede llegar a dificultar
aún más la solución de un conflicto que
tendría que llegar y que tendría que ser
resuelto tanto por armenios como por
azerbayanos
haría pues muchísimas gracias por este
reportaje desde cara baja
a vosotros ya ustedes también gracias
por acompañarnos en reporteros de france
24 recuerde que si quieren ver esta
emisión no duden en ingresar a nuestra
página web las 24 punto com hasta la
próxima semana
[Música]